In the previous video, splitting
this three-pack of soap
with my wife, she cut it
right down the middle.
So we each got half of all
three bars, or we got 3/2,
or each of us got
3/2 bars of soap.
Now, just to make
sure that we really
understand what 3/2
is-- and remember,
3/2 is really the same
thing as 3 divided by 2.
If someone says 3
divided by 2, you
could say, hey, I'm going
to represent that as 3/2.
Or someone says 3/2,
you could say, well,
that's the same thing
as 3 divided by 2.
But just to really
understand this number,
let's actually think about
where we would plot it
on a number line, as well.
So let me draw a
number line here.
I'm going to start that as 0.
Let me draw a line,
as straight a line
as I am capable of drawing.
And let's say that this
right over here represents 1.
So that would be 1 bar
of soap in this example.
And let's say that this
right over here is 1/2 bar.
This is 1/2 bar.
And let's say that
this is 1 and 1/2 bars.
And let's say that this right
over here is 2 bars of soap.
So we have 3/2.
So let's think about this.
Remember, 3/2 is 3 times 1/2.
Or, since we already
split this into halves,
we just have to go
3 of these halves.
So let's do that.
So this is 1/2.
This is 1/2.
Now we're going to have 2/2.
That takes us to 1.
And we know that because
2/2 is equal to 1.
And now let's do our third half.
Our third half is
right over here.
And so that is 3/2.
And we see 3/2 is the exact
same thing as 1 and 1/2.
Now, just to hit
that point home,
we already saw that 3/2 is the
same thing as 3 divided by 2.
If you were to divide 3 by
2, you would get-- well,
2 goes into 3 exactly one time.
And then what would
you have left over?
Well, you would
have 1/2 left over.
So 3/2 is the same
thing as 1 and 1/2,
which is exactly
what we saw here.
You could view this as we
have 1 and 1/2 bars of soap.
And this is where you would
plot it on the number line.
3/2 is halfway in
between 1 and 2.